[Musik]
Einsatz für Rettungswagen 12041
Feuerwache Berlin Mitte zwölf Stunden
von 7 Uhr morgens bis 7 Uhr abends ist
die Besatzung unterwegs um Leben zu
retten
ich bin angeleitert Brandmeister bei der
Berliner Feuerwehr bin 33 Jahre alt und
fahre heute Rettungswagen 1204 eins von
Mitte ich bin Nicolas sommerich bin 23
Jahre alt bin jetzt im zweiten Lehrjahr
um Notfallsanitäter zu werden mein Name
ist Sebastian Günther ich bin 49 Jahre
alt seit 24 Jahren Feuerwehrmann und bin
Notfallsanitäter Praxisanleiter auf der
Feuerwache Mitte
von den fünf Rettungswagen der Wache
sind heute nur drei im Einsatz es fehlt
an Personal
am Alexanderplatz da fahren wir jetzt
hin und dann gucken wir mal was uns
erwartet
hinten im Behandlungsraum bereitet sich
Notfallsanitäter Sebastian Günther auf
das Schlimmste vor Günni für dich wir
haben suizidankündigung
am Gleis 2
Einsatz auf dem U-Bahnhof kann bedeuten
dass die Notfallsanitäter auf Menschen
treffen die sich vor den Zug werfen um
ihr Leben zu beenden in diesem Fall
kommen die Feuerwehrleute rechtzeitig
die Untersuchung ergibt der Mann hat 3,4
Promille im Blut
das sind Patient der ist hin und wieder
alkoholisiert und droht dann an sich was
anzutun ist aber stadtbekannt und da ist
der Ablauf dann halt üblich wir fallen
in der psychisch und da kann ich denn
kurieren lassen über 600 Mal hat die
Feuerwehr diesen Mann schon in die
Psychiatrie gebracht im Krankenhaus soll
der Betrunkene ausnüchtern doch er
entweicht und wird am selben Tag noch
einmal die Feuerwehr beschäftigen wieder
mit einer Selbstmorddrohung
während Rettungswagen 12041 durch diesen
Einsatz blockiert ist herrscht auf der
Wache Notstand
mein Name ist Markus Raabe ich bin 35
Jahre alt bin der Wachabteilungsleiter
auf der Feuerwache Mitte in Berlin die
einsatzkarte zeigt dem
Wachabteilungsleiter wie wenige
Rettungswagen kurz RTW in der Hauptstadt
in diesem Moment zur Verfügung stehen
Alarm bekommen dass unser alarmzettel
dann drauf steht wo er hinfahren müssen
das Problem ist da wir stadtweit gerade
noch zwei rdws verfügbar haben ist der
lanweg relativ weit das heißt wir haben
eine Anfahrt von ungefähr 26 Minuten was
natürlich dann bei dringenden Notfällen
für den betroffenen Patienten sehr
ungünstig ist
kaum hat RTW 12041 das Krankenhaus
verlassen schon wartet der nächste
Notfall
wir haben ein Platz Zustand bei
unbekannten psychiatrischen Notfall
der Patient hat selbst die 112 gewählt
Depressionen Selbstmordgefahr mit
Blaulicht jagt der RTW durch die Stadt
zu oft wird die Fahrt von Autos gestoppt
deren Fahrer nicht schnell genug Platz
machen Stress für die Feuerwehrleute
wenn jede Sekunde zählt doch die
Situation am Einsatzort ist anders als
erwartet der Patient steht vor dem Haus
gesehen schmeißt sie weg
der Mann der den Notruf gewählt hat
steht mit Koffer vor der Tür und möchte
ins Krankenhaus gebracht werden der
Notruf als taxinummer die Kosten für die
mehrere hundert Euro teure Einsatzfahrt
trägt der Steuerzahler denn auch dieser
Patient hat Selbstmord angekündigt
ankündigt für uns dann ist es Notfall
dann müssen wir ins Krankenhaus bringen
aber er hat natürlich auch alleine
fahren können aber mit dem Stichwort
müssen wir noch auf jeden Fall mitnehmen
auch wenn der Job bei der Feuerwehr ihr
Traumberuf ist die oft unnötigen
Alarmierungen frustrieren besonders
nachts
wir sind hier im Kiez in der Innenstadt
der tippt hier Freitag und Samstag
Nächte und ernst ist relativ vermeidbar
sind 80 Prozent in den Kiez in den
Mächten also wenn es kein Alkohol gäbe
hätten wir in nachts ganz wenig zu tun
in einen Stadt also klar hatte ich schon
erwartet dass es mehr
Unfälle gibt und mehr schwer verletzte
und sowas aber gerade dieser
alkoholgeschichten und so das ist hat
man sich so nicht vorgestellt nein also
ich habe das Gefühl jetzt in meinen drei
Jahren jetzt hier bin dass die Leute
sehr hilflos geworden sind
dass viele nicht mehr Plan B im Kopf
haben wen könnte ich vielleicht noch
kontaktieren für die kleineren Sachen
die vielleicht haben können da kann ich
mein Nachbar Fragen für dich Bekannte
fragen kann ich vielleicht auch mein
Taxi ins Krankenhaus fahren das ist gibt
es alles Möglichkeiten die man machen
kann aber das wird gar nicht mehr drüber
nachgedacht sondern es wird einen den
eine einfache Weg gewählt und das sind
auch Sachen die uns dann halt auch
belasten dass wir halt viel fahren was
nicht nötig ist auf der Wache
Berlin-Mitte kommt ein Löschfahrzeug vom
Einsatz zurück die Feuerwehrleute sind
ausgebildete Sanitäter und halfen bei
einem Unfall denn der Rettungswagen war
zu weit entfernt eine Notlösung denn
Patienten transportieren kann das
Löschfahrzeug nicht das Problem ist dass
wir dass die Kollegen ebenso oft auf dem
Rettungswagen sind und so viele Alarme
fahren dass wir dass wir auf Verschleiß
fahren und dass wir dadurch auch einfach
Personalausfälle haben und dadurch haben
wir halt auch viele langzeitkranke und
es fallen halt immer mehr Kollegen aus
16 Uhr nach neun Stunden ist Zeit für
eine Mittagspause heute ist sie 15
Minuten lang als Beamte haben wir
offiziell keine Pause aber wir haben die
Möglichkeit 15 Minuten lang das Auto
nach dem Einsatz mal sauber zu machen
und das lässt sich dann kombinieren so
not hier drum Auto sauber machen frische
Sachen anziehen und dann noch schnell
ein Essen und deswegen
gegen Ende der Schicht wird RTW 12041 zu
einem Verkehrsunfall gerufen ein Mann
ist mit einem leih-roller gestürzt hat
schwere Verletzungen
wir haben jetzt eingepackt vakuumiert
weil wir nicht genau wissen was für
Verletzung alles hat und jetzt behandeln
wir ihn weiter im RTW also das sind
einer wofür wir ausgebildet worden sind
das sind genau die Einsätze die
Feuerwehrleute wünschen sich
Unterstützung entweder müssen mehr
Sanitäter eingestellt werden oder die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger müssen auch
unnötige Anrufe unter der 112 verzichten
damit die Feuerwehr nicht selbst zum
Notfall wird